[Applause]
i said to him i know he wants to kill
and he said i wrestle he wrestles in
east texas in one of these little
circuits you know youtube i don't think
so
until you where what you're wrestling at
shotgun remington cole
colt
get the [__] out of here right now if i
bring you on stage can you show me a
move
get the [__] up here
tell me a little bit about your
character
uh i'm a hunter
i'm a [__] right
[Applause]
with a bow and arrow
can you show me something without
killing me
i don't have a whole lot of confidence
in this guy
he didn't see when i asked him that did
he seem super confident
when i was like can you do something
without killing me he kind of shrugged
his shoulders yeah
can you show me a move without me
just a solo move
a leg drop
will you bring jacob out [__] that
that's [__] up you think i'm gonna
like
this dude disfigure my son just for the
[__] bit yes i will
no
[Applause]
um
so here's deal i'm in between on letting
him do something how long does it shoot
that up from the [__] top
i love people from 100 yards away
what are you wearing in the ring
uh tights and all the even smaller types
of tights
tights over tights
and so if we're gonna do this move are
you gonna are you gonna disrobe at all
are you going straight you're not
when you wrestle in front of people you
wrestle your shirt off though right
[Applause]
i'll take mine off too you'll be ready
before we do this
we have to have a plan she's not gonna
be two shirtless guys on stage
we're not just gonna stand next to each
other and be like hey
so what's the plan what are we going to
do
suplex
you first bro are you kidding me right
now a suit plus
like you're the one where he breaks your
neck i'd love to see that one
come up here for a second
okay
okay so this is where we can cult
he's a he's a professional wrestler
we were thinking about going shirtless
and doing a wrestling move how do you
feel about that yeah i heard you call me
out here and then i saw you guys want to
take your shirts off so i'm probably
just going to go back in the great room
are you going to go
now listen guys
[Applause]
this is interesting
let me tell you something right now
you know we can be wrestling twins and
be the meaty nipple brothers
do you need a little trash talk
[Applause]
[Music]
if it's me okay hi
i put you in the spot yeah man this is
live all right here we go
all right uh
[Applause]
hey first of all
that hurt more than i thought
but second of all can i tell you how
happy i am that that just happened
guys he'll he'll attest to this i i love
[__] that has never happened to me i
hope there's like a little turkey hand
on me
yo
i'm not gonna lie to you like i'm gonna
put this moment top five things has ever
happened
and by the way we're
recording this set so
our nipples are going to be on the
internet
well last night we had we i was
shirtless on stage with this dude who
said he was a professional wrestler and
i said do a move on me and he wound up
like this
and just
guys i have a
i have a hand mark like that yeah you
know in first grade when they were like
thanksgiving draw a turkey that's what i
have
i can draw a turkey on my chest right
now there's a [__] legit thumbprint
i'm like if he was a murderer you could
get his prince off of my chest
and you should eat you pretty hard real
hard you take it like a chat though
[Music]
foreign